ça va j'adorais l'accrobranche d'hier
mais moi ça va je suis un peu fatiguée
mais ouais ça va je suis heureux
on fait le cercle du matin et ensuite on
fait les activités donc par exemple on
peut proposer des activités d'anglais ou
des maths ou pas ou un jeu dehors c'est
elle libre en fin de peau
un petit coup dans la serre pour
rempoter des petites plantes moi je vous
propose une sorte de causes orientation
chasse au trésor a créé vous-même on
propose avec Thomas clair un atelier
anglais donc c'est très court c'est
vraiment une demi-heure maximum moi je
vais bien vas-y moi j'aime bien
moi je trouve ça mieux que en classe
tous les jours
ça fait un moment que je suis plus à
l'école
je me fais pas beaucoup d'habitude à
l'école parce que quand j'y allais la
récré c'est horrible
cet endroit c'est l'écho village de
Bourges c'est en Ariège les habitants
ont acheté le domaine en 2017 pour
expérimenter un autre mode de vie basé
sur la liberté 42 personnes dont 18
enfants ils vivent actuellement chaque
famille possède sa propre habitation
et du coup on avait tous vraiment très à
coeur de faire autre chose du système
éducatif et une éducation pour nos
enfants différents on avait créé des
écoles différentes on appelle les écoles
démocratiques qu'on était soit des
créateurs fondateurs de ce type d'école
soit des parents qui avaient mis leurs
enfants dans ce type d'école soit des
personnes qui gravité autour de ce
mouvement qui a pris naissance en 2015
alors j'ai besoin de deux volontaires
pour aller planter des rhubarbe
et on va essayer de les planter ici là
un petit peu à ce que c'est que le
cultiver ce qu'on mange et voilà avoir
un peu les mains dans la terre être en
connexion des insectes ne pas en avoir
peur et voilà tu as joué avec des vers
de terre dans les mains elles en ont pas
peur elles savent l'importance des vers
de terre dans le sol c'est rigolo parce
que il y a plein de vers de terre
et un peu aussi avoir des nuages
c'est ce qui m'a un peu ouvert la porte
à la parentalité cette possibilité en
fait d'éduquer les enfants comme ça
comme moi j'ai été un peu éduquée aussi
attends je vais faire un peu plus
ça me semble indispensable en tout cas
oui voilà c'est bon
capucine il aime bien apparemment
il est calme il est vraiment posé
voilà je mets toujours une petite
musique sympa
cette ambiance sympa les matins tous les
matins il est là avec moi dans la serre
j'ai envie de l'intégrer le maximum dans
de mon quotidien dans mes activités j'ai
envie de lui transmettre un peu qui je
suis et qui sont les personnes qui
composent notre environnement de vie et
j'ai envie de pouvoir du transmettre le
plaisir de faire les choses le faire
avec avec enthousiasme avec avec le cœur
et ça forcément être dans
la pression sociale ou la pression
familiale de devoir faire des choses par
normes de société ou par besoin sociétal
juste parce que tu as envie de le faire
et c'est ça qui te fait plaisir et moi
c'est le plus important
[Musique]
j'imagine qu'elle richesse pour nos
enfants aussi parce qu'on a chacun nos
compétences nos connaissances donc
effectivement notre une autre façon de
réagir avec avec les enfants
alors on peut faire les trampolines avec
vous
oui
avoir passé une vingtaine d'années à
ingurgiter du savoir de la connaissance
à avoir été mis en compétition face à
l'autre à devoir toujours être meilleur
que l'autre pour pour avoir une position
sociale qui est confortable on le
voulait pas pour nos enfants en fait
parce qu'il y a un cadre scolaire il y a
un pas de cadre scolaire ici
chaque famille a ses propres cadres mais
en règle générale les enfants ici en
sont pas scolarisés le fait de pas
mettre son enfant à l'école ça s'appelle
l'instruction en famille c'est légal et
il y a des contrôles parce
qu'effectivement qu'on soit dans le dans
l'environnement école ou dans un
environnement familial il y a une
obligation de fournir les moyens
nécessaires à l'instruction
des enfants ne vont pas à l'école je
suis consciente que ça peut choquer
puisque moi-même en tant qu'ensienne
preuve éducation nationale j'avais même
pas conscience que l'école était pas
obligatoire c'est après quelques années
que j'ai compris que l'alliance avec
l'instruction est obligatoire mais
qu'elle peut se faire les différentes
façons je suis consciente que ça peut
choquer et je suis ravie de tout voir
accueillir et expliquer pourquoi
aujourd'hui moi ça ne me choque plus et
pourquoi même j'y vois quelque chose de
beaucoup plus optimal beaucoup plus
pertinent beaucoup plus épanouissant
c'est complexe
l'apprentissage de lecture est très
complexe mais en tout cas les
ingrédients pour moi qui sont essentiel
c'est motivation intrinsèque et donc la
motivation intrinsèque c'est ok j'ai je
trouve du sens à ce que je fais c'est un
intérêt c'est relié au réel c'est une
situation concrète et je suis accompagné
je suis pas seul et si ces ingrédients
sont là en fait il y a plein plein de
choses qui se mettent en place le
collectif accueille régulièrement et
équipement des enfants de la région
c'est l'activité touristique comme des
séjours vacances et les différentes
formations pour adultes dispensés par
les membres du village qui permettent de
faire vivre financièrement le lieu
est-ce que vous quelqu'un a une idée de
ce qu'il a envie de faire ah oui
comme ça
oui oui
tu n'as pas peur qu'un jour ta fille te
reproche d'avoir fait le choix pour elle
de ne pas la mettre à l'école au début
alors comme moi cette peur elle non elle
est pas là parce qu'on discute
énormément avec nos enfants on discute
régulièrement de déjà de mes peurs à moi
parce que je peux avoir des peurs
effectivement parce qu'on est quand même
une pression sociale nos parents notre
famille nos amis qui disent tu fais
n'importe quoi donc effectivement des
fois on peut se remettre à douter
en fait ouais en fait on décide et c'est
en fait c'est pas notre décision là
aujourd'hui c'est ne plus note décision
c'est la décision de notre enfant
aujourd'hui elle sait totalement qu'elle
est libre d'aller à l'école en fait je
ne la contrainte pas à ne pas aller à
l'école
oui je vais mal parce que là je vais
partir je suis très petites obligations
c'est le cercle de départ en début de
journée et le cercle de clôture à la fin
et le ménage en fait de clôture c'est
pour dire comment elle s'est passé la
journée si tu t'es bien amusé et
ben ça c'est que certaines personnes
mais dire ce que tu aimerais faire
demain voilà
bah moi ça va j'ai passé une bonne
journée je me suis bien amusée à part au
moment où j'avais plein de pailles sur
moi
finaliser entre guillemets par rapport
aux autres enfants qui eux vont à
l'école je sais pas si c'est une crainte
ça peut être une réalité
on nous même on n'a pas envie d'être
marginalisé en vivant ici dans un
collectif de vie donc on a plein de
toujours des connexions avec le reste du
monde ne serait-ce que par de famille
nos familles sont importantes dans nos
vies donc elles viennent ou aller voir
du coup ils sont mélangés aussi avec
leurs cousins alors cousines qui vont à
l'école et l'école n'est pas un secret
pour eux il existe une école et
d'ailleurs certains ont eu envie de
faire un test ils sont allés à l'école
de la commune d'en bas pendant deux mois
pour certains un an pour d'autres
c'était intéressant moi intéressant
voilà ils ont appris des choses en tout
cas on n'est pas contre l'école mais
vraiment mettre de la conscience tu peux
y aller tu peux tester tu vois ce que ça
t'apporte tu vois les contraintes et si
tu veux pas y aller tu veux quand même
apprendre des choses bah il y a plein
d'autres manières d'apprendre ces
choses-là parce qu'il y a pas une part
de naïveté aussi derrière cette
philosophie bah écoute peut-être il y a
une petite part de naïveté mais en fait
c'est la naïveté pragmatique et réaliste
en fait on n'est pas des on n'est pas
des
uruberlues
on vient tous d'un de ce monde de ce
monde où voilà on avait des vies avant
quoi donc c'est des choix qu'on a fait
conscients et
je pense qu'il faut une certaine part de
naïveté ou d'insouciance pour faire ça
oui mais c'est pas négatif
[Rires]
[Musique]